so every morning i wake up i kiss both
of them
we equally fight when we make up we
equally come and we all start kissing
we put like this at the little tree at
kiss
[Music]
i get jealous when i see my partner with
someone else
three two one
go
um i just didn't do strongly disagree
because i mean of course jealousy is a
factor in polyamory but
it's something that we just communicate
about and i do get jealous
occasionally yes i think in other parts
of our lives like work
friend family we kind of like suppress
that jealousy you can't really act
out on it so why when it comes to
relationship you can just go and act out
on it and get mad at your partner for it
or you know tell them you can't talk to
this person or that person
i found through polyamory that i like
thrive off of love from multiple
people and i don't think i'm somebody to
take that away from people i love
either so i feel that it would be wrong
for me to feel jealous when it's
something that i want
instead i replace it with the word even
a lot of polyamory people don't know
which is compersion
which is like the opposite of jealousy
where i actually feel really happy when
i see my
significant other with somebody else
yeah so
i haven't been in a quad right where
there have been four of us and we were
all sort of
internally dating one another but i have
had three girlfriends at once and those
these were parallel relationships while
jealousy isn't like a super huge problem
that i deal with
it can emerge from other things other
than seeing them with someone else right
we've been married for 14 14 19
or so yeah 13 14 yeah 14 years yeah yeah
we've been married
we just realized that not one person can
fulfill all your needs
ingrid and i just did it for a minute
honestly like we actually were friends
for like a year
and then she realized she was out of my
league
and we remained friends since you know
and you couldn't handle me
[Laughter]
my family approves of my relationship
three two one
go
okay so i'm actually like over here like
on the other side of this line
because i come from a traditional korean
christian home and me marrying a puerto
rican
was unacceptable they pretended like he
didn't exist hoping he'd just go away
night before the wedding are you sure
two weeks before the wedding my mom was
like you know you can still call it off
right
and um so it was it was pretty rough
which is why i'm not actually
out to my parents uh i don't really talk
to them very much there's no way that i
can even approach this subject
you know which is kind of why i'm here
today because i want to show people hey
look we exist
you know and it's okay coming out to my
mom it took
actually a couple years and so her
reaction was more of a curiosity where
she was just asking me questions about
it i think her unconditional love
was the acceptance of our polyamory that
now she's able to show it off and talk
about it to people
that they don't understand and she's
able to like that's my daughter
you know so it's pretty awesome wow they
support my lifestyle i don't necessarily
think that they quite
understand it when i have undergone
separations or breakups with partners
and try to rely on my family for a
little bit of emotional support to help
me grieve those losses um sometimes i'm
met with like
well you got another partner i don't see
what the big deal is right i guess the
way my
parents my mom has always seen it she's
always seen like i'm in a relationship
where i'm like
a slave maybe in the background and
these girls are telling me what to do
and controlling my life
taking away all my money i was really
emotional during our wedding because
i i didn't expect my my mom not to show
up to the wedding
i thought she was gonna be in the
background just like mad you know
they've always done a really good job
of going to all my sport events to
everything that i've done in life
they've always been there except for
this one moment even our gender reveal
they didn't show up to the gender reveal
either
you can cheat in polyamorous
relationships
three two one go
when you date somebody who's monogamous
right or let's say that they're married
and because you're polyamorous they're
like oh hey look you know she's easy or
you know he's available
that's cheating you're not cheating
because you're being honest
but their partner is not consenting to
the relationship that you're having with
that person
it is still an individual decision of
mine to say okay well
am i going to involve myself or not i
mean sure i think that clearly they're
cheating and i may try to encourage them
to
you know like say hey you should tell
them figure it out what's up but
i'm not cheating i'm done you know what
i'm saying do you really want the other
partner to show up with a shotgun
exactly because
i mean we've dated girls before the
second we find out there was someone
else
boom it's over as a conceptual question
could you guys cheat within
your polyamorous relationships if two of
you were to engage one another without
the third one
would that constitute cheating in some
senses well my answer because i met them
uh together i don't see that if they
were in the mood that that would be
cheating
if they you know if they told me about
it or whatever just because their
relationship
was what it was there's times where i'll
start fooling around with her and she'll
come out of the shower
but before we we finish the other person
will be there
you can 100 cheat and the reason being
like we're
open to pretty much everything like
we're allowed to have sex outside of the
relationship we're allowed to date other
people we date people together
but the problem is is if you're not
honest about it i just swiped on
bumble whatever went on a date and i
didn't tell her anything that's cheating
i want children
three two one go
oh this is not an answer i guess
i went from wanting four kids to two
kids to zero
once we started paying bills and living
in los angeles i was like i can't do
this i'm of the mind of if we have
children
somebody has to stay home to raise them
i'm going to raise puerto rico i came
out here to pursue a career that
i have successfully made a living off
and she started her own business
are you going to give up your career to
raise a child she's like no
she's like are you going to give up your
career to raise a child he's like no it
is kind of selfish on our part and we
understand
that it's not the norm necessarily but
for us it's just
it's worked out and we love our life
we're happier we're happier for it
i strongly agree because i have a
nine-year-old already so i mean i just
felt like it would be a little weird to
be like yeah i strongly disagree right
but i do think it's a separate question
though right of whether or not i'd like
to bring more life into the world right
and this is something that i talk about
and think about with with partners uh
and the like but polyamorous children or
children born unto polyamorous families
um aren't necessarily protected by the
state or the society in the same way
that people born into dyadic or
monogamous units are
who can access marriage and so on and so
forth so she's only 21 i'm only 23 so
obviously there's gonna be some problems
with that financially and stuff like
that but we do talk about having kids i
want a little boy
and like you need to raise him but i
i don't know i just don't think i'm
ready we never wanted to have children
we were probably in that side
way over there you know and after
discussing the whole marriage thing
we're like well once we get a house and
we do this we'll we'll eventually take
that journey
so we got a house then we actually ended
up getting married now she's pregnant
congratulations yeah this is a baby bump
okay we found like a birth center even
through covet that will allow all three
of us in the room when the baby's born
and then for the babies we're gonna do
like a power attorney so that all of us
could have
the same type of guardianship over the
baby any medical or anything like that
we actually found that this year three
dads were put on the same birth
certificate right for their kid
they actually wrote a book about it i'm
really interested in learning more but
with that that means it's possible
i am equally committed to all my
partners
three two one
go
i really am somewhere between these two
can i what about is here good
i i i'm struggling with the
understanding equal
i don't think equal means the same so i
know i don't have the same commitment
how i orient myself towards keeping my
commitment
i do think is the same it may look like
to an external eye
that i don't have equal commitments to
them all right so
i think that's why you're on this side
closer than on that side is because
you're willing to be present whether it
be for
one or the other like for me it's dating
a male and a female like i can do
cha-cha's eyelashes but definitely not
jimmy
so there's totally that difference but
like the willingness to be present for
your partners whether they want
that same affection or not it's that's
why i think you're a little more on this
side than on that side even if you're
not all the way over here
yeah that's why i'm on this side too is
the fact that you know i'm committed to
making my relationships work i'm
committed to that person
and to bringing to that person what what
they need from me
and then if i can't do it then the
relationship doesn't work openness
communication obviously being like okay
i have a partner this is my main partner
maybe they just want to have sex or
maybe they just want to go on dates or
have somebody to cuddle with
this is my primary partner so they
are a priority at the end of the day i
feel like if we had a third
person in our relationship it would be
equal and we would be on that side
she's my nesting partner she's my
primary partner she's the person that i
have built my life
around and that's how i understood the
question it's not that
my other partners are disposable i mean
i would take a bullet for all of them so
every morning i wake up i kiss both of
them
you know if i'm at her she gets mad at
me we
equally fight we equally come together
when
we make up we equally come and we all
start kissing
like this looks like the little tree had
kiss
and then after that kiss everything's
good and then we go out to eat
and to eat yeah yeah
and i like to add because i knew that
hierarchy existed so when i met them
knowing that she's a girl and i could
feel kind of that feeling of if someone
were to enter my relationship how i
would feel
i never wanted to step on her toes for
me it was very fluid and open and okay
to the point where i like hyperactively
wanted to make sure she was okay even
getting her pregnant we all discussed it
and she was you should go
get pregnant first my future
relationships will be
polyamorous three
two one go
if i could find somebody who covers
every single base
which i honestly i'm not really sure if
it's even possible but if they cover
every single base i
you know wouldn't need another partner
i'd piggyback off of that because i'm
similar right so for me i said earlier
right like my polyamory is not a numbers
game it could be one person
it could be more than one person my
future relations will be polyamorous i
definitely mean like sort of like this
polyamory in principle
and not necessarily in like number for
us we uh
we started out monogamous and then we
opened the door to polyamory and
there's no shutting that door and the
idea that um
you know like ingrid was saying like
would you need another person well we
believe we would need another person to
do different things with
um i would like my future relationships
to be polyamorous
but i also understand that life happens
sometimes
if you were to get married or have kids
you know like you might not have the
time to be in a polyamorous relationship
and also because we're open i feel like
any discussion like you can talk to me
about anything
so if my partner came to me and was like
hey i think i want to be monogamous i
would definitely be open
to that idea too so it's not necessarily
that i will be doing this for the rest
of my life but i do want
the ability to be open to it i don't
want to be fully monogamous
but i guess i am open to it like you
said with marriage and there's many
factors that go into it that's the only
reason i'm not on strongly but i would
more than likely
want to be in a polyamorous relationship
even throughout my marriage
well that is officially a wrap for you
guys
[Music]
you